this is an ineb it's a nebulized
electronic
machine which converts a small amount of
liquid drug
into a fine mist the scientists involved
in the trial claim it could be a game
changer
a drug known as sng01 an inhaled
formulation of interferon beta
is administered with this device a
nebulizer
it's early days but the first tests have
shown the treatment prevents kovid 19
from advancing
in 79 percent of cases and also helped
speed up recovery
this is crucial as it can prevent
patients from needing intrusive
mechanical ventilation
in intensive care if we could see the
drug effectively reducing the risk
in a larger population of going on to
events later
it does alter the whole dynamic it
alters the likely outcome for the
patient
it alters the burden on the health
service it alters the
duration of illness and it alters the
risk ultimately of dying
we've got an early signal of that and we
need to pursue that further
to see if that's going to be a useful
way of treating the disease
sng001 is administered directly to the
lungs via a mesh nebulizer
it gives the patient a concentrated
dosage of
interferon beta a naturally occurring
antiviral protein which covid suppresses
interferon beta triggers the production
of antiviral genes and proteins
which neutralize the virus it also helps
cells by boosting the immune response
preventing further infection together
it appears to prevent or diminish
further cell damage
and viral replication so far the trials
have been small
101 volunteers all suffering from
covid19
who'd been admitted to nine uk hospitals
half the patients were given the drug
the others were given a placebo
the results of the trials have not been
peer reviewed so
there are still question marks over what
the scientists working here have found
but if interferon beta does do what the
company says
it will be a significant advance in the
fight against the coronavirus
professor stephen evans says the results
are encouraging
but there's still a long way to go it's
promising
if what we think we've seen
now proves to be true in large numbers
then it's very important but we ought to
be cautious we ought to be british
and not go overboard in saying
this is the answer because we simply do
not know yet
the scientists certainly still have
plenty of work to do
bigger trials subject to approval from
medical regulators
could take place soon the hope is in the
event of a second wave of covert
infection
the medicine would be widely available
alex rossi sky news southampton